So once you've set up
the billing account,
it's time to create a new project
using the Create Project button.
Enter the human friendly name for
your application.
I'm just going to call it My First Map.
Then you enter the project ID.
This ID needs to be unique across
all of Google's infrastructure, so
you'll need to get specific here.
As you can see,
I've just called it udacityfirstmap1,
because this isn't taken and
it's available.
Then you select the billing account
that' you're going to use, and
if you remember when you're
setting up the billing account,
you gave a profile name, and I have
a profile that I call My Cloud Project,
and I'm just billing based off of that.
Then you just click Create.
As you can see,
it will take a few moments creating.
But when it's done, you'll be
taken to the project dashboard.
Now you can see I'm on
the project dashboard.
So the first thing that I
want to do to enable maps,
is to go to APIs off, then select APIs.
And here's a number of APIs
that are available to me.
But we can see there
are Google Maps APIs here.
So I'm going to go to the Google Maps
Android API and I'm going to enable it.
Now that it's enabled, the final
step is to set up the credentials.
Over here I can click on the credentials
link, then under public API access,
I'll create a new key.
When it asks what type of key,
I'm going to select Android key
because I'm building an Android app.
It will give me a dialogue asking me for
the SHA1 that I got earlier,
followed by the name of my app.
Because I'm not deploying this app,
or doing anything with it that would
require the certificates to check,
the restrictions are much looser.
And one of these is that
the name doesn't really matter.
But I am going to use the fully
qualified name of my app.
The SHA fingerprint is what we
got in terminal earlier on.
Let's take a look at that.
Here you can see my SHA1 key.
So I'm just going to copy all of that,
and then I'm going to put a semi-colon,
and after the semi-colon I'm
going to put the name of my app.
In this case, it's
com.google.devplat.lmoroni.firstmap.
Don't worry if you need
to change the name.
You can do this later with the edit
allowed android applications button.
But, I'll just create for now.
And we can see that my
key is listed here.
And if I wanted to change my name,
I just say, Edit,
allowed Android applications.
And I can go ahead and change the name.
The API key is listed at the top.
Make a copy of that, or
keep the console open,
because you'll be needing
that in the next step.